ALEX FAABORG: All right.
Welcome and Good Morning.
Thanks for coming.
I'm Alex Faaborg.
I'm a designer at Google.
My background's in cognitive
science and machine learning.
And at Google, I've worked on
Google Now and on Glass and on
the Android platform.
And giving design talks at
venues like I/O is really one
of the favorite parts
of my job.
I really enjoy doing it,
especially being able to
talked audience of engineers.
You guys are obviously smarter
than most people.
It means I can move
very quickly.
There's a lot of slides
in this talk.
So we're going to
have to dive in.
So how many of you
are engineers?
Quick hands.
Yep.
All of you.
Awesome.
Makes sense.
It's a tech conference.
So you write great software.
You make sure that your software
executes well or is
interpreted well on a silicon
based processor.
But that's really the
first time that your
code is going to run.
It's going to run it again
on another machine.
So you start with the mechanical
computation, which
is of this entire conference is
about and is very important.
But then there's
another phase.
And that's the biological
computation that's happening
right after.
And this is really where your
code is actually being
interpreted, is on
the user's mind.
So the more you can understand
about both of these machines,
the better software that
you're going to write.
And it's important to focus on
some of the attributes of what
we know about biological
computation.
So a very quick overview
of the talk.
Here's my very rough diagram.
We're going to spend about
half the talk on vision.
And then the second half the
talk we'll be focusing on
attention emotion memory.
Diving into vision--
During the opening sequence
we went through a
lot of optical illusions.
Of course, no cognitive science
talk is complete
without a few optical
illusions.
This one is physiological.
We're basically overloading your
rods, where the little
white dots are popping
and becoming black.
So this is basically just pure
hacking of hardware.
But what's more interesting
is this one.
This one is not physiological.
This one's running on software,
where the lines
appear to be slanted.
They're not.
They're horizontal.
But nonetheless, your mind is
interpreting it because the
very powerful video codec that
you have that's grabbing all
this raw data is trying to do
certain optimizations based
off of expected input in the
types of things you see in the
real world.
Another example is this one,
where it really looks like
there's a gradient on the bar.
The bar's a flat color.
The gradient's only
in the background.
And the reason for this effect
is what we're used to natural
lighting environments.
We're not used to this thing
being able to happen, where
you can have a flat color
and a gradient into the
background.
So all of our evolution has been
optimized for the types
of things that we're
likely to see.
So it's taking short cuts.
It's increasing the amount of
difference that you can very
quickly see the edges
and changes in shape
and changes in shape.
So one of things we're great
at is edge detection.
This is actually my favorite
optical illusions.
It's called the Kansai
Triangle.
And what's cool about this
is there's isn't actually
triangle in the shot.
But you perceive a right
triangle in the foreground.
It's being created
out of nothing.
And when you look at the edges,
you almost feel like
you can see the shadow
on the edge, even
though it's not there.
Your mind is making assumptions
on the triangle
being in the foreground.
And that edge doesn't exist but
nonetheless you feel like
you can see the shadow,
which is very strange.
So a lot of other cognitive
scientists and designers, many
years ago, came up with the
Gestalt Laws of Grouping.
And this is something
that all designers
will learn in school.
And there's eight of
them for grouping.
We only a little bit of time,
so we'll go through three of
them specifically.
First one's the Law
of Proximity.
By introducing white space, you
perceive columns, instead
of just the same number
of shapes.
When it's uniform grade, you
just perceive all the shapes.
But as soon as you have a little
bit of white space--
your mind is very good at
finding patterns and assigning
order to things.
So you very quickly assign
that into three columns.
So you don't have to draw boxes
around everything to
create grouping.
You can just use a little
bit of white space.
So an obvious example
of this--
Google search results.
By introducing just a little bit
of white space in between
the search results, it's very
easy for people to group those
and chunk them into individual
results.
Whereas if that white space
didn't exist, even though you
have all the formatting cues--
bold titles and the
blue underlines.
Those things still exist.
But it's still very hard to be
able to see that structure
without the white space.
Obvious analogy to writing
software is trying to look at
code without white
space is hard.
I mean, a computer can interpret
it just fine.
In fact, white space is probably
wasting a little bit
of bandwidth.
But nonetheless for you as a
developer, you need that to
see the structure.
Another Gestalt Law of Grouping
is the Law of
Closure, where we very quickly
complete forms.
It's not actually full circle or
full square, but we quickly
make it one.
So again, you don't have to draw
boxes around everything.
In the case of Android, just
having the little edges on the
text field is enough for
your mind to mentally
complete the box.
You begin to see the box.
And the box exists in your mind,
even though it wasn't
literally drawn on the screen.
Law of Similarity--
here, instead of columns,
we're seeing row.
And the only thing we changed
was level of contrast of some
of the objects.
But the rows pop out.
And it doesn't have
to contrast.
It could also be shape,
where seeing stars
versus circles, where--
the rows really pop
out at you.
And we this in Gmail, where--
in this case, columns.
You have a column of check boxes
and column of starring
messages and a column of
priority, where it's very easy
to then visually scan down that
column, even though the
spacing is all uniform.
It's otherwise just a grid.
So those are all things
that are innate,
that apply to everyone.
There's also some aspects of
layout that are cultural, that
you pick up over time.
One of the most basic one of
these is reading right to left
versus left to right.
This is very important for the
structure of your application.
It's not just about the text,
but it's about the logical
flow of the application, where
the meaning of a switch being
on versus off should actually
be inverted, if it's
horizontal switch.
I should note-- the back
button is wrong.
As I was a taking the screen
shot, I realize this.
We'll fix that.
But the notion of back is
opposite, if you're used to
reading right to left, instead
of left to right.
And this applies to really know
the whole structure of
your application.
And things like going
up in the hierarchy.
In the action bar,
we see that.
We didn't do that correctly.
Or even things like the Settings
button being sort of
peripheral to activating a
keyboard in this sense--
there's a certain flow to it.
And that flow should
be reversed.
So a whole new topic related to
vision-- peripheral vision.
Let's say we have an underground
testing facility,
where we do studies on people,
of course for science.
And we keep people isolated.
So we don't about
the studies are.
So they don't know any idea what
the study is going in.
But we give you this
test chamber.
And we ask you to go
into the room.
So you go in.
And bam-- tiger.
That's the only test.
Basically, we're just monitoring
how long it takes
you to realize that there's
a tiger in front of you.
And it's going to be about 190
milliseconds to recognize that
tiger that we very carefully
set on the podium.
It's probably hard to get
him to stay there.
And of course, he
then kills you.
But that's not part
of the test.
That part's arbitrary.
And it's up to the tiger.
So let's run another study.
At this point, subjects are
kind of talking, say these
chamber's are no good.
So you go in.
There's nothing.
Once again, bam-- tiger.
And what's interesting about
this is you'll see this tiger
in 80 milliseconds.
We've actually evolved to have
faster peripheral vision for
detecting motion in objects
because of tigers.
There's a very legitimate for
this is all the people who had
vision that was uniform,
between central and
peripheral, they'll get
killed by tigers and
the rest of us survived.
And we're very good at seeing
movement and change in our
peripheral vision.
It's highly tuned for that.
So what's this have to do
with interface design?
Obviously, we don't exist in
environments where we have a
lot of predators anymore.
We're all information workers.
But nonetheless, you can use
this in your design.
So let's say that I'm
modifying this
product-to-plan document.
And then my PM shows up.
And this is his actual
at avatar
picture up in the corner--
of the tiger, tying
it all together.
And what's interesting about
this is it's actually easier
for me to see that notification
of him arriving
in the document, when that's
being cued off of my
peripheral vision, verses if it
happened right in front of
me as an editing text
and things.
So that same effect of grabbing
the user's attention
of notification--
it's actually easier
in their periphery.
So another new topic
related to vision--
geons and object recognition.
So we recognize a lot of
objects in the world.
We're constantly encountering
new objects.
There's millions, potentially
billions of them.
So the question is how do we
actually store all of this in
our own software?
And this is some of the
most recent research.
The idea is that we have a core
vocabulary geometric objects.
And people argue about
the exact number
of how many it is.
But people are gravitating
towards there
maybe being 24 of them.
And even just 24--
any three of them, you could
create greater than 306
billion combinations.
So that's robust enough that
it could be working.
But basically the idea is when
you look at an object, you
immediately break it down into
the geons that it contains.
And then you use that
to do the look up of
which object it is.
So here you got cylinder
and the curved candle.
You do that look up and
say, oh, it's a cup.
And this applies to even more
complicated objects, where, as
you're perceiving it, you're
constantly just breaking it
down into the various core
geometric objects and then
using that for recognition.
So what's interesting
about this--
not exactly tigers.
But you will recognize the
silhouette, the basic geometry
of the shape, faster than you'll
recognize an icon that
is more photo-realistic
or rendered.
Now it's a very small
difference.
So you might have been able
to perceive it as
you're watching yourself.
But nonetheless it's kind of
interesting that, if you
really care about speed and
subtlety and having a truly
optimized design, these sort of
silhouette, basic geometry
shapes actually do recognize
faster for the user.
And this is also--
there's a lot of aesthetic
reasons why you might want to
use one versus the other.
For instance, on the Android
home screen, where we can't
control the background, we opt
for using the more rendered
icons because they have better
contrast on variety of
backgrounds.
But also on Android, the hollow
icon set is entirely
this flat icon style, in part
due to aesthetics and also in
part due to this recognition.
So you can very quickly
spot things in here--
camera or joystick or battery.
As soon as you see these things,
you very immediately
know what they are.
So another type of object
recognition we do is facial
recognition.
And this is actually done
on a completely
separate hardware path.
You're not looking at someone's
face and breaking it
down into various geometric
objects.
You have an entirely separate
set of hardware in your mind
that's purely dedicated
recognizing faces.
So let's take you into
another test chamber.
At this point, you're
really worried.
And you go in, and you think,
oh my god, it's
full stock-art people.
And they're all walking
towards me--
even worse than tigers.
And in this test, it is
all stock-art people.
And they're kind of
creepy perfection.
But there's one person and
who's actually a friend.
And the test is how quickly do
you see your friend as all
these people walk towards you.
And you'll see them
very quickly.
You've probably have already
about perceived this at the
conference, where various people
conference-- you're
seeing a lot of cases,
obviously.
But you'll quickly spot these
people that you know.
You might not remember their
name, which is a whole
different thing.
But you'll definitely know that
you recognize them as
someone that you've
met before.
And you're able to do this by
taking in all the faces
simultaneously, which is
also very interesting.
You're not having to do a very
linear scan between each face
to process it.
This is all just happening in
the background, on the full
visual field.
So in terms of implications
for interface design--
if you're looking to see a
particular email came in from
say James or Ruth, with this
type of design you're going to
have to do when your scan
down the list and
read each of the names.
But if we start using faces,
then you can get that effect
of all the hardware that
we had built for facial
recognition.
So for instance, the
Glass Timeline--
as you're browsing through it,
you can very quickly find
particular pieces of information
because of those
pictures of faces.
So if you're looking for a
lunch appointment, you'll
recognize Richard there and
you'll see a very quickly.
And you don't have to do that
scan as you would for text.
So any new topic related
to vision--
perceived affordances.
Every single time people talk
about perceived affordances,
they talk about doorknobs.
I'm starting to think that maybe
people think it's only
about doorknobs.
So we'll do a whole
new example.
So again, test chamber.
And yeah, there's
not a doorknob.
That's not the test.
You have to go through door.
And the way you figure out how
to go through the door is a
perceived affordance because you
see the physics of how the
thing's going to slide.
But you go into the
test chamber.
And there's pieces of trash
on the ground floor or
some type of object.
And what we're trying
to figure is,
do you recycle correctly?
And the answer is, usually no.
People are actually pretty
lazy about this.
They're busy.
They're thinking about
other things.
They just look at all
the trash cans and
just throw it in one.
What's interesting, though, is
if you change the trash cans
to have slots that match roughly
the types of objects
that should go in them,
recycling actually goes up
34%, or correct recycling.
Because, as you're holding a
piece of paper, you just sort
of think, yes that is where
I should put this.
And you slide it in.
And you're doing this processing
very quickly, just
as you look at a doorknob, you
make immediate inferences
about its physics, on if
you're supposed to
push or pull it.
So an image that, of course,
had been circling around
inside of Google--
Sometimes hiring the smartest
people isn't enough, where,
no, the milk jug is
not compostable.
But I would argue, first of
all, they were probably
thinking about a very hard
computer science problem as
they did this.
And secondly, based on perceived
affordances, that
was the correct slot for
something milk jug sized.
They were doing all
that processing.
They just weren't reading
any signs or
really paying attention.
And these types of perceived
affordances obviously have a
lot of impact in the
physical world for
doors and trash cans.
But they also have an impact
in the virtual world, with
things like buttons, sliders,
where can see the physics of
the object as you
just take it in.
And it immediately visually
conveys to you how you
interact with it--
on and off switches, or even a
check box that can or cannot
contain a check inside of it.
So another topic about vision--
color deficiency.
So most of us in the room
have three cones--
tri-chromatic vision.
And some of us in the room will
have two cones, where you
could-- most commonly, you'll
lose either the perception of
red or perception of green.
It's also possible to
lose perception of
blue, although that's--
its more rare--
Tritanopia.
So there's a general the
misconception that when you're
colorblind, you actually
perceive the world in
monochrome, which is not true.
It's much more common to only
lose one of your cones through
a mutation.
And there's also a general
perception that you shouldn't
use red-green differences
in your interface.
So let's look at an interface it
uses red-green differences.
And we can very easily simulate
what this appears for
someone of Deuteranopia or
Protanopia or Tritanopia.
And the reason it works is
there's more than just color
in the values.
You also have the level
of contrast.
So even though you're losing
that red-green difference,
you're having very clear
contrast differences.
So instead of just making
assumptions on which covers
you should or shouldn't use.
It's better to just run them
through filters, your
interface, see what it actually
looks like for people
in that population set,
make sure things
are working out OK.
And there's a lot of-- if go
online and just search for it.
There's a lot SVG filters that
you can apply to an image to
see the change.
There's a java application
that you can
download to do it locally.
Or if you have Photoshop--
amazingly enough, it's actually
in the menu of Photoshop.
As I was researching this,
I was kind of surprised.
I had never seen this before.
You can just go to View, Proof
Set Up, and actually--
unfortunately for
the people with
Tritanopia, they aren't included.
But [INAUDIBLE] very easy if you
have Photoshop to quickly
check out an interface.
And what's sort of interesting
is a mutation causes you to
have two cones versus three.
But you can also have
a mutation it
gives you four cones--
tetrachromats that have
superhuman color vision, which
is really cool because each
cone gives you about 100
ranges of color.
So we all have about a million
colors that we can perceive.
Tetrachromats can perceive 100
million colors because of
their fourth cone.
And this is also extremely
common in other species.
Birds, for instance, all
have four cones.
The fact that we have
three primary
colors is kind of arbitrary.
If we were a society of
birds, we would have
four primary colors.
Birds can perceive ultraviolet
light.
There's no design implication
here.
It's just cool.
So moving on--
colors and culture.
This is not innate.
It's something that's
learned over time.
Concepts like to red, at least
in the West, are usually
pretty negative.
Red tape, in the red, these
types of phrases.
Whereas in Japan,
red is actually
very celebratory color.
It has connotations
of lanterns and
festivals and happiness.
Of course, their stop signs are
still red for consistency.
I guess those are more
celebratory stop signs.
But they've a very
advanced culture.
But it's important to sort of
think about the various
implications of the colors
that you're choosing.
But that's not true
for all colors.
Other colors are
more universal.
For instance, gold
is universal and
not just as a color.
But it's sort of universal
in the universe.
And this has implications on
Android design, where we use
gold to mean the
monetary value.
This of course localizes very
well to pirates as well.
So let's go on Selective
Visual Variables--
another test chamber.
Now this is a great
test chamber.
This is a test chamber that you
actually get to go into.
And the winners will get
Android plushies.
So hopefully you'll win.
The task is--
I'm going to show you a range
of letters and numbers.
And the first person to
correctly shout out how many
red letters or numbers
there are, just red
shapes total, wins.
And I'll time you.
So--
we'll see how long
this takes you.
All right.
Begin.
[AUDIENCE SHOUTING ANSWERS]
21 over here.
Who was the person
who said 21?
You?
All right.
There you go.
Sorry, Angela's going to
help me hand it out.
OK.
Let's try again.
And that took about
15 seconds.
All right.
Your next task is how
many G's are there.
[AUDIENCE SHOUTING ANSWERS]
All right.
16.
Who is--
Who's the person who
said 16 over here?
Yep.
You're right.
OK.
That took you about 20 seconds
and there were less of them.
And you were all shouting out
completely random numbers were
not accurate at all.
So the implication for this is
that color is a selective
visual variable, while
shape is not.
In computer science
terms, you can per
color in constant time.
Going back to the spread.
As you look at it, the color's
all coming in, just as you can
do face recognition
constant time.
Whereas for shape, you're having
to do a very clear
linear scan-- look this shape.
Is it a G?
No.
Move onto the next.
Is it a G?
No.
So this is an important effect
for your interfaces, this type
of visual processing, that if
someone's looking for shapes
they're going to have to
do that linear scan.
So the implication for
Google search--
by using color for title and
then also for the domain, the
full URL, you're able to then
very quickly in your mind to
do a selective--
it's sort of filtering
on that color and
then scan just those.
And you can pop to them, just
as you're popping tall with
the red letters,
counting them.
So if you're looking, for
instance, for berkeley.edu,
you can say, not it, it, without
having to read any of
the other information.
That covers vision.
Let's dive into the attention,
emotion, and memory.
First, we'll talk
about attention.
This is an fMRI machine.
And what's really amazing about
this machine is we can
actually look at the minds and
see how it's operating on a
physiological level.
And this is how we
know everything
about how mind works.
So very, very, rough, high level
overview of the mind--
you have working memory and
you have long term memory.
And that's a super
simplification.
And now to make a bad analogy on
top of the simplification--
working memory is kind of like
a clipboard on the computer.
You store things there
for a moment.
And then you're done
with them.
Whereas long term memory is a
little bit more like storage.
Now there's a lot of ways in
that it's not like storage.
In fact, when you access your
memories you also modify them.
So read and write are tied
together, which is one of the
reasons that memory is so
unreliable, unlike a computer,
where you're able to read
without writing to the file.
Also sleeping is kind of like
defragmenting your hard drive.
But this is rough analogy.
So what's important about
working memory is the user is
going to be strong things their
working memory as they
go throughout their day--
various things that they're
working on, software they're
writing, variables--
any number of things.
And then if they receive an
interruption what happens is
the interruption captures
their attention and the
working memory fades away.
So you wouldn't write software
that was actively deleting the
contents of the clipboard,
right?
You obviously care
about data loss.
But when you create interruptive
notifications,
that's what you're doing.
You're deleting the clipboard
of the user's minds.
And this is why interruptions
can be so dangerous and cause
people to be very ineffective
throughout their day, if
they're constantly getting
email toasts and they're
running around putting
out fires.
You're doing a lot of thrashing
on the user's thread.
And they're losing a lot of
data, as the thing that they
were storing was lost.
So another aspect related to
working memory is chunking.
Basically what we're doing here
is because you're working
memory so limited in size,
you're putting things on it
and then taking them
off quickly.
So I was trying to find an
example in Google products--
a little bit hard because we
don't have a lot of serial
numbers or anything.
But for two factor
authentication, when you have
a recovery password, we
chunk it, based off
of four letter sequences.
So it's easier for you
to then write it in.
If we didn't have
these spaces, it
would be very difficult.
You'd be grabbing as much as you
could possibly store and
then going back and trying to
find where you left off.
More commonly you see this
of credit card numbers.
If you ever create an
application that doesn't let
the user enter spaces on a
credit card number, you're a
very bad developer.
Also, if you actually generate
an error because they entered
spaces, you're just a
horrifically bad developer.
So please, please,
don't do that.
It doesn't matter how
smart the user is.
They could be brilliant.
They still have a limited
working memory, as we all do.
And we rely on, in this case,
Gestalt Proximity with the
white space, for being able to
grab the various chunks and
move them over.
In other aspects related to
memory is interruptions and
the concept of flow.
So as the user is holding
their working memory and
they're doing these creative
tasks, if they're really
focused they can get into this
particular psychological state
called flow.
It has a few attributes.
Usually have a very clear
goal when you're
doing creative work.
You're very focused.
You're receiving constant
feedback.
And this also affects your
perception of time, when some
people report that time almost
seems to stand still when
they're in this state, whereas
other people report that time
goes extremely quickly.
So, for instance, when you're
playing a musical instrument,
if you're very good instrument,
you're not
actually thinking about the
sort of physicality of the
instrument itself.
You're just creating music.
Or perhaps a more common
example-- if you're playing a
video game, you don't think
about the controller.
You get lost in the narrative
of the game and you start to
have the world kind
of fade away.
Same with reading a book.
You to think about turning the
pages, just sort of lost in
the narrative of the book.
And, of course, same with
writing software, where you're
not really thinking about all
the tools you're using.
You're thinking about the
creative endeavor of writing
the software.
And what's important is when
you create interactive
notification, you're not just
deleting the working memory,
you're also pulling
them out of flow.
And it can actually take quite
some time for them to get back
into the psychological state.
So another topic related to
attention is line length and
reading speed.
There've been a lot of
studies on this.
So if you have very lines of
text, people can consume
information faster.
So for instance, Google News
here, as you're reading these
headlines you can fly through
them because you don't have to
do a break onto the next one.
However, if you ask people what
they prefer, they say
they prefer shorter lines.
So it's this, are we force
feeding them information or
not argument, where, yes,
they're are more efficient and
optimal with long lines.
But it's not as comfortable.
So you see an application like
Currents on Android, which is
a new news reading app.
By having very short lines of
text, it becomes a more casual
and browsable interface.
And it's not as intense as
reading these very long ones.
So moving over into emotion--
one of the first aspects
of emotion is trust.
And just as we're designed to
recognize tigers very quickly,
we're also designed to make
trust decisions very quickly
because we evolved in a state
where we had to decide, is
this thing going to kill me?
Can I eat this thing?
These were very basic
decisions.
We had to them very quickly.
We don't have to make them
quickly anymore, but
nonetheless these first
impressions start to stick,
where you're choosing a bank.
And you look at this bank and
you think, well they clearly
been around for a while, perhaps
a few centuries, based
off of that column.
And if it gets really windy,
like my money's not going to
blow over, because it's
very, very sturdy.
So this is probably good bank.
And maybe it's a horrendously
corrupt bank.
But you form of these immediate
trust decisions.
This comes into play in the
virtual world as well.
Let's say you're writing
financial software.
And the user has to decide
which of these two
applications they trust.
And they don't know anything
else, like the developer could
be brilliant and also indie
and not corrupt at all and
writing really good stuff
with Money Pro
using Comic Sans and--
versus this one, where it's a
3D render and has little bit
of texture.
And it's just a great icon.
And what's interesting is once
you formed that decision on
which one you trust, then as
we give you additional
information, you start to tell
yourself these made up stories
to try to justify your
original assumption.
So we say, well look Money Pro's
got four stars, whereas
this one only one.
You say, well yeah but maybe
this one didn't work on all
the devices.
Those people are just
mad because they
couldn't have its greatness.
Or maybe it's really
expensive.
I haven't looked at
the price yet.
And they're just mad.
So you start to create these
theories, even though we've
given you evidence that,
not, that one's better.
You've already made your
initial trust decision.
So the obvious implication
here is first impressions
matter a lot, especially for
interfaces like an app store,
where people are very quickly
choosing one amongst others.
It's very worthwhile to invest
in your application icon and
create that very first
impression, to be very solid.
So text and culture--
not innate but learned
over time.
Obviously, we think about
threads and exceptions and all
this terminology and jargon
of software development.
It's important to think about
the environment the user's in.
If you create a dialogue box
that says, this application
has performed an illegal
operation.
You don't actually know the
geopolitical environment that
the user's in.
This might actually scare
them quite a bit.
So please don't do that.
Another great one is,
unfortunately, earth has crashed.
I was trying to crash Google
Earth to get that one.
And I couldn't crash it.
But, it does exist,
that dialog.
Jumping over into memory,
off of attention--
talking a little bit
about learning.
So again, we have working memory
and long term memory.
And the task here is to transfer
something that's just
in the very transitory,
ephemeral working memory into
your long term memory.
And once we've done that
transfer, you've
learned this new thing.
And there's two ways
to do that.
The first is to associate
it with something
they already know.
If you can form that linkage,
it'll transfer very quickly.
And then if they don't have that
linkage yet, the second
way to do it is through
repetition.
So let's look at an example
in interface design.
One of the things the users
immediately have to get used
to on an Android is that all
their apps are in a separate
place, whereas the
home screen is a
customizable home for them.
So we need to tell them
your apps are here.
If you to get to one of your
apps, hit this button.
This was a screen that
we rolled out
in Ice Cream Sandwich.
It actually doesn't
work very well.
And reason for that is they
realized that they're blocked,
so they don't read anything
and they just
hit OK really quickly.
There's no repetition.
We only told them once.
It wasn't linked to anything
there ready know.
So they start to play
with the phone.
And then they say, well
where are my apps?
Then they proceed to hit
everything until they
finally find it.
So an alternative design
could be--
we can't really to something
they know, so just repetition.
If we just had this refrain for
the first number of times
saying, all your apps are here,
that would start to set
in after just a couple
of times.
Or after they'd hit the Control,
then we'd stop
showing it.
By doing this--
it's not as loud or as broad
as that intrusive,
interruptive flow that
we initially had.
But this would actually
perform better.
It performs better because
of the repetition.
Now if you're linking to
something that the user are
already knows, it's OK to just
have a single reference that
they might ignore.
So for instance, let's say
you've already use the
commenting system a lot.
And now we say, you can also
chat with document
collaborators.
It's an adaptation of
something you've
already been using.
Here, because it links to that
existing knowledge, this'll
perform pretty well, even
though it's just
that one time interface.
So another aspect of learning is
recognition versus recall.
Now the classic example is the
command line versus graphical
interface, where the command
line's very difficult because
you have to, in your own memory,
remember all the
commands are and access
them over time.
And--
it's actually a little bit more
complicated than that.
That's true.
But there's more going on.
And essentially what we're
doing is cognitive load
balancing, where in order
of difficulty,
recall is very difficult.
Visual targeting is moderately
difficult.
And then movement
is very easy.
So if we look at a variety of
interfaces, a command line
versus the graphical interface,
the graphical
interface is going to perform
better because it's mostly the
visual targeting and movement.
I can remember that there
are alignment tools.
I can't remember what
they all are.
But I'm able to look there and
say, oh OK, a line left, and
hit that button.
So it's a interplay between me
and the interface, where I'm
remembering some things.
It's remembering other
things for me.
And it's able to augment my
memory because it's being
shown graphically.
And then the visual targeting
is a little bit of work.
Interestingly, the voice
interfaces are, at least in
terms of cognitive load, more
similar to a command line.
The pulsing mic is kind of the
new blinking cursor because
you have to remember, like for
instance what all the Android
Voice Actions are.
And--
can anyone name all Android
Voice Actions?
Yeah.
So that's still, in the recall,
very high cognitive
load category.
And then also interestingly is
we're seeing interfaces that
are in some ways just
about movement.
So like invoking Google Now,
once you've learned that
behavior, you don't even have
to do any visual targeting.
You're just swiping directly
up off the bottom of the
screen to do it.
So it's in many ways one of the
easiest interfaces because
it's only on that third track,
which was the easiest.
Also swiping through the
timeline on Glass-- you're not
doing very much visual targeting
because it's such
low information density.
And you just have the single
cards in the timeline.
And you're just doing the gross
motor skills of Swipe or
Accelerometer looking.
So those are very easy
interfaces, at least in terms
of cognitive load.
Another topic I want to talk
about with learning is the
notion of learning
with examples.
Now, often people say, well,
we need to create this
interface in this particular
way because it's similar to
this other product
that exists.
And users aren't going
to use it otherwise.
That's not entirely true.
You can show the user
an example of
how something works.
And now it's consistent.
Their futures experiences are
consistent with that example.
So they've effectively
learned it.
People are pretty smart.
So you're able to actually
create innovative software
that changes things from the
existing marketplace and
playing field.
You just have to bring people
up to speed on why you made
this changes.
So a couple examples of this--
in 2006, the notion of
the end of files.
Obviously, people are very
used to the file system.
They're used to attaching
things, sending them around.
That's kind of broken.
So how do you get this huge
marketplace that is very sort
of set in the consistency
of how files
operate into a new model?
And the answers is you just
lay out a very quick
argument for it.
MALE SPEAKER: Meet Sam.
Sam is the editor of a
neighborhood newsletter called
The Oak Tree View.
She works with local writers who
like to publish articles
in the newsletter.
Sam loves her job but often
feels frustrated when time is
wasted managing all
the 'articles.
It's a familiar problem.
Each month, writers send her
draft articles as email
attachments.
She reviews them and sends
them back with comments.
One article might create six
different versions of the same
file, not to mention the
countless emails.
Sam often feels buried by all
the email attachments.
She finds it hard to track all
the versions being sent to her
from the writers.
As the deadline looms,
frustration rises.
Something has to give.
Sam decides to try something
new, Google Docs.
Here's what happens.
First, she visits the Google
Docs page and creates a free
Google account.
She logs in.
And because some articles were
already written, she uploads
the current drafts right
from her computer.
With a snap, Google
Docs turns offline
articles into online versions.
Now all she needs to do is
invite the writers to
collaborate on the documents.
ALEX FAABORG: So there, you lay
out a very simple problem.
You show the solution.
Sam is sad.
Sam has too many files.
And people are able to very
quickly then adapt to that new
model because they
have been able to
learn from that example.
It's not the case that you
have to be consistent.
Looking at another example--
2012, 2013--
The notion of predictive
assistance.
When we were working on Google
Now, we were worried about--
it's going to be really hard
to explain this to people
because people are so
used to search,
especially with Google.
People are extremely used to
search because Google such a
search company.
How do people wrap their head
around the notion of a product
that's going to give them the
information that they need
right when they need it?
And the answer is you show them
a couple of very simple
examples to lay out the
nature of the product.
And from just those examples
they can start to extrapolate
new use cases in
their own mind.
So here's a quick spot we
created for Google Now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: Bonjour.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: A fruit or
a vegetable, do you think?
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I don't know.
I can ask.
[SPEAKING IN FRENCH]
MALE SPEAKER 2: It's a fish.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: Oh.
ALEX FAABORG: So three
very short examples--
and I'm only showing
a clip of it.
But from that, you can
understand the
nature of the product.
And we're finding when we told
people, so this thing is going
to predict the information
you need.
They would look back
and say, OK what?
That makes no sense.
But if we said, you're standing
on a train platform.
You want to know when the next
train's going to come.
So you go in it, and the
schedule's already there.
They say, oh that's
pretty cool.
From the example they're able
to then grapple onto
[INAUDIBLE]
and then imagine
other examples.
That was act one of laying
out this notion of
this augmented reality.
Of course, act two is then
saying to people.
And it's going to augment
your vision.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 3: After this
bridge, first exit.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Woo hoo.
MALE SPEAKER 5: Hurry up.
A12, right there.
ALEX FAABORG: So this product
is great for when you're
running down escalators is
the consistent notion.
Because we're showing people
being so busy that's also
important for the
predictiveness, where they
don't even have time
to quickly look up
their flight details.
They need to get the gate.
And it's right there.
So what's important here is
that consistency is--
[MIC FEEDBACK]
Sorry.
It's making noise against
my phone.
Consistency is not critical.
It really bothers me that
that's one of usability
heuristics that people
focus on.
You do not need to build
products that are identical to
what exists in the
marketplace.
What you can do is you can have
innovation and teaching.
And people are smart, like you
don't have to design for the
first-run interaction.
You can bring people up
to speed over time.
And they're going to understand
your product.
And you can create interesting
products that aren't just
leveraging what's already in
the marketplace for the
purpose of usability.
So the final topic I want
to focus on is the
perception of time.
So interesting example
here-- just looking
at a progress bar.
In this case, it's a pretty
simple progress bar.
We look at another one.
This one it slows down.
You're like, come on, come
on-- and then finishes.
Versus the final one, where
it starts out OK.
And then it speeds up
towards the end.
And of course, all these
progress bars are taking the
same amount of time
to complete.
But what's interesting is we're
actually really bad at
gauging how long
something took.
We don't really have an
internal chronometer.
What we're doing is we're
perceiving the process of time
based off of change.
So something that speeds up
towards the end, is actually
going to appear faster than
something that slows down
towards the end, even if
the overall amount
of time is the same.
And they're been a lot
of studies on this.
In fact other products, have
had slow progress bars.
And everyone complained that
file copying got slower, even
though it was actually faster,
which is crazy.
So it's important to know
these types of effects.
They're can actually be a 10%
variance in how long something
people think something's
going to take.
Another example of this is if
you're working on something
like the Web Layout engine,
where obviously there's a lot
of people working very hard
at making that quickly.
So your immediate assumption
could be, well we'll just do a
layout as things come in.
As soon as we have it, we show
to the screen, quick feedback,
it's all going to be great.
What's interesting is because we
we're so bad gauging time.
And we only gauge time based off
of the individual changes
and how many changes
there were.
That will actually appear to
take longer than if you were
just pause and then bring
everything in
once you have it.
Because we mentally chunk that
white space of before.
And we don't really know
how long before was.
We just know that, wow I
have my whole page now.
And it came in very quickly.
So there are all these aspects
of how we're perceiving time
that come to play with the
performance of your
applications and how you
can optimize for that.
And our perception of time it's
kind of like an optical
illusion, where we're not
perceiving reality.
We're filtering everything
through our own hardware.
And if you learn about our
hardware, and if you learn
about the biological
computational machines that we
are and that your software
actually runs on, you can
write better software.
And you'll be a better
engineer.
So some quick recommended
reading, if you want to check
out some books--
Don Norman, famous cognitive
psychologist.
Susan Weinschenk has a very
book came out recently.
Also of course, all the
writing from the
injury design team.
And before you read those books,
you can spend your
entire day learning
about design.
This was the first session.
In the same room, we'll
have three more
sessions about design.
And then if you head
over to Room 12.
There's Android design
for UI developers.
So now we can take some
quick questions.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I think very quick questions
because we have
about a minute and a half--
one question.
[VOICES FROM THE AUDIENCE]
Ah yeah.
Sure.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you for coming.